aux invalides
il y avait cinq années j'ai été
accueilli comme si j'étais pas fille et
de mon le fait sûrs du dialogue et des
discrets ils prennent leur temps ça fait
toute la différence
je fus jeu monsieur monsieur pour moi
c'est pas important c'est essentiel
qu'un vieux soldats soient accompagnés
jusqu'au bout et que les jeunes seule la
voie que si un jour il aura bien quelque
chose entre s'occuperait deux comme ça
[Musique]
c'est vraiment un
c'est un beau l'ua et les nations
vous connaissez peut-être ce lieu pour
son dôme doré pour le musée des armées
ou encore pour le tombeau de napoléon
mais aux invalides se cache aussi un
hôpital pour brut je vous emmène dans
cet endroit pas très connue en plein
coeur de paris
nous on soigne on répare et on vient en
aide aux blessés de guerre
l'institution nationale des invalides ou
ligne et il ya 350 ans par louis xiv
elle accueille encore aujourd'hui des
militaires blessés au combat des anciens
combattants mais aussi des victimes des
attentats comme jamel qui a été blessé
le soir du 13 novembre 2015 et qui
continuent de s'y rendre pour s'occuper
de sa prothèse on va voir qui on va voir
s'ils résistent tu vas kiffer
des tours de magie
petits réglages à le pied kablan on va
j'avais dit aux libertés tifo les
pantalons hockey non
non vers la zone de change tout
simulation mieux
dans la tête ça c'est les réglages ou de
faire régulièrement quand on adapte en
fait à chaque patient puis prend de
l'autonomie à la marche la marche aussi
changent donc on adapte l'hôpital
je peux me fier comment ça fonctionne
concrètement la prothèse donc c'est un
principe à vide d'air donc le patient
bien chaussé sur lui sur le moignon donc
manche on l'accueille en gel de silicone
sur lequel ensuite il va venir mettre
sur le dos du temps limité et ensuite
l'extrémité de la prothèse nous avons
totalement tir au tour donc dès que le
patient va se chausser dans sa prothèse
l'oea va être expulsé par la dalle et ça
tient pas parmi eux 200 m je vais
pouvoir qui s'est très facilement sa
place à un gel à chaque fois et ce jeune
qui va sécher thérapies non je suis pour
le projet pour descendre quasiment porté
sur sa bouche ou le 1er février 2007 je
suis arrivée ici je connaissais pas du
tout je connaissais pas du tout les
invalides
je n'avais jamais entendu parler schwehm
un pas qu'il y avait un hôpital
ici il faut savoir que la prise en
charge est totalement différente de
l'hôpital l'hôpital c'est je pense
qu'ils sont sont pas prêts à ce n'était
pas prêt en tout cas recevoir des
blessés des grands blessés de ce type
parce que au delà du physique et aussi
l'aspect psychologique et c'était
c'était compliqué ici sont plus ils sont
plus aptes est ce que ça peut apporter
quelque chose de vous présenter de
côtoyer des militaires aussi bien sûr
bien sûr d'ailleurs me
il avait vachement de compassion je
trouve envers nous ce qu'ils savent être
con ce qu'on avait vécu et il se doutait
bien qu'on n'était pas aussi prêts que
psychologiquement à avec ces choses là
aussi il ya une vraie prise en charge tu
vois il ya du dialogue qui se crée il ya
ils prennent leur temps et ça fait toute
la différence
franchement c'est ils sont vraiment bien
occupés nous comme ça ont su me concerne
je me dis voilà s'il n'était pas là je
sais pas comment ça sera fini non
dès le début de son histoire ligny
travail avec les meilleurs médecins et
les meilleurs chirurgiens du pays
les méthodes utilisées à l'époque était
innovante et moderne
aujourd'hui il ya des kinésithérapeutes
des dentistes des cardiologues et même
des ergothérapeutes
tout est fait pour que les patients est
un parcours de soin complet l'imi est
dirigée par un médecin militaire le
médecin général inspecteur michel guy c
le centre médico-chirurgical prend
notamment en charge des jeunes
militaires blessés en service après un
accident par exemple comment alors moi
en fait je suis militaire donc je suis
sapeur pompier de paris fait partie du
groupe de gymnastique
c'est un groupe de démonstration qui se
produit dans toute la france et aussi
dans le monde entier et du coup lors
d'une démonstration au fait j'ai fait
une chute au trampoline en fait sur la
tête
aujourd'hui je suis tétraplégique
complète et je peux bouger que mes
épaules et ma tête les invalides le
permettent aussi de faire des cours
d'informatique
c'est à dire que je m'entraîne en fait à
utiliser un ordinateur
du coup aujourd'hui à la fois comme ça
si un jour je réintègre la brigade
j'aurais déjà un outil à disposition la
chaîne devrait revenir
du coup dans les bureaux et tu peux pu
partir sur un terreau nation on nous a
dit que j'avais pas mal
tombeur exactement ce que c'est qu'on a
toujours été vachement soudé c'est
vraiment une force qu'on a la brigade
c'est la cohésion et je sais que même un
an et demi après ils sont toujours là et
c'est ça qui me donne le moral fabre et
donne envie d'aller plus loin alors là
le but de l'exercice d'aujourd'hui c'est
que je suis en plein 17 fauteuils donc
le but de ces du coût de l'achat d'un
fauteuil électrique et là du coup on va
faire un carton
exactement je peux régler ma vitesse et
surtout mes trajectoires et
l'inclinaison de mon fauteuil à lomé au
tour à la roya venger une valeur des
slaloms il va en dépendre il va y avoir
des marches arrières des passages dans
des endroits autre que le bitume donc de
l'herbe t4 à pied voire un peu près
comment le fauteuil se comportent et
surtout comment moi j'arrive à le manier
c'est bon
il ya des points d'appui en fait sur ma
gauche la droite et derrière moi et du
coup pour tourner je dois appuyer
légèrement sur la droite légèrement sur
la gauche et j'aurai une aussi ma
vitesse en appuyant à une intensité
différente au niveau de ma tête plus je
vais appuyer plus accès donc là on va
sur le plateau technique celle en vo ou
les kinésithérapeutes manipule et
soignent leurs patients et on va voir
amy qui a été blessé en mer lors d'un
accident d'hélicoptère
j'ai eu ma séance ce matin j'étais sur
un bateau de la marine
je suis directeur de pont d'envol et un
hélico un hélicoptère s'est crashé donc
en scratchant les débris sont partis on
pense que c'est une pâle que j'ai pris
dans les jambes donc bien là ça fait
quelques quelques dégâts il ya tibia
genou
et quelques quelques autres partis qui
ont été éjectés qui on est et qui ont
été brisés déchiquetés elles ont fait de
lambeaux ils appellent ça des lambeaux
donc ils ont pris un morceau de mots les
uns des muscles du mollet pour combler
le trou qui avait dans le jeu nous ont
finalement c'est moins normal mais ça
aurait pu être plus haut ça aurait pu
être des gens là exactement et un ans à
perdre les jambes perdre bien plus
méchant mais les jambes
évidemment je m'en sors plutôt bien
bien sûr il ya quand même des gens qui
ce qu'ils sont des entorses à la
cheville et m'ont effectivement c'est un
peu plus mais avec ça je suis quand même
destinée à angie d'autonomie de
à une vie quoi levin en quoi il ya les
centres spécialisés pour la rééducation
sportive un pia ce centre là qui est
vraiment on côtoie des militaires de
toutes générations qui ont qui ont tous
leur façon de voir la vie
les opérations et tout ça c'est assez
sympa tout ça c'est depuis son ouverture
l'institution nationale des invalides a
toujours accueilli des soldats blessés
et c'est encore aujourd'hui le cas avec
ce qu'on appelle les pensionnaires ce
sont des militaires des anciens
combattants des victimes collatérales de
la guerre et même des rescapés
d'auschwitz
tous ont en commun une invalidité
suffisamment importante pour habiter
être totalement prise en charge par
l'institution est donc là on va aller
voir george ii sur qui est le
représentant des pensionnaires lui c'est
un ancien qui va vous le raconter qu'il
a été placée blessé en 1944 comment ça
va comment ça va bien
un gain sur le sujet pensionnaire depuis
combien de temps alors 6 jours 6 ans
vous êtes bien si que je suis très bien
mais je peux dire que ça a été un
aboutissement
pas tout à fait prévu et qui m'a comblé
dans solitude alors je suis retourné sur
les origines des mesures c'est à dire 75
ans
ils se souviennent huawei j'ai été
accueilli comme si j'étais partir de mon
pote ayant surtout les gens qui avaient
eu forcément mais finit par et moi et
j'ai retrouvé un esprit de que une
fraternelle georges qui les
représentants des pensionnaires et
membre de la garde à l'étendard dont il
est le porte étendard onu lui tourne on
nous nous allons présenter lui tant
d'heures pour le foot ou sous il faut
participer au dîner officiel ça c'est
une photo qui ont bien dû apporter au
dernier 14-juillet le tableau final
c'était les blessés d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui
il est modeste mais c'était l'homme je
ne peux être que modeste opposants de
gens présents que le que driver
relations voilà c'est ça c'est important
pour vous je trouve
c'est un général qui a fini son parcours
mais qui reste en tenue au contact
auprès des vieux soldats pour leur
exprimer quotidiennement la gratitude
des français donc je suis leur frère
leur papa leur conseiller leurs
confidents c'est un titre honorifique
c'est pas un gros job c'est quelque
chose où il faut mettre son coeur sur la
table servir les anciens ils m'ont
appris il faut voilà il faut donner mais
je vais faire dans cette institution il
ya aujourd'hui 80 pensionnaires et ce ne
sont pas que des personnes âgées
il ya aussi des jeunes militaires
français comme césar un soldat de
l'armée de terre qui a été blessé lors
d'un accident pendant une opération au
sahel highroad là demain super vue sur
le magnifique dôme des invalides les
oreilles c'est effectivement il est
chargé soir trois cent cinquante ans
d'histoire
quand vous est l'occasion de discuter et
de rigoler avec avec des gens qui
étaient au gîte
c'était à tellement longtemps -
trentenaires comme je vous ai dit c'est
dans les livres d'histoire qu'on apprend
ça et là en fait le fait de côtoyer ces
gens-là de manger avec eux de ramasser
des potes et ils ont 95 ans en temps il
ya des choses qui se partageaient
c'est vraiment un effort ça a vraiment
symbole sûrs c'est vraiment un beau lieu
si l'hôtel nacional d'eisai c'est
vraiment le panthéon des militaires
l'institution nationale des invalides
c'est la maison-mère du minuteur beasley
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh